What are the expectations that we're setting?
There's two different types of expectations, right?
There's expectations in terms of like actual results,
how many leads, how many phone calls,
and then there's expectations in terms of like
when the website's gonna get set up,
when we're gonna be doing this,
we're gonna be doing that,
when things are gonna be live.
What are the expectations
that you are setting with the client?
In terms of like timelines and stuff like that,
I never, and I hate to say this, but I don't promise.
I never say, oh, it's gonna be done
in 72 hours or three days.
I never give them precise answers.
And it's not because I'm trying to be sketchy.
It's because I know from the past that things can happen.
And if I'm 12 hours late or a day late,
I don't want them to think that I'm not reliable.
So I tell them, hey, it's roughly a week,
and then I would rather get it done sooner,
which kind of goes back to how you do sales.
Like you always wanna undersell it.
So that's what I always do.
I don't promise.
If somebody asks like,
how many leads am I supposed to receive?
I never, ever, ever, ever say, oh, a minimum of 10.
Never, because you can't predict that,
and you would be lying if you were telling them,
oh, at least 10, because how do you know
how many people are going to the call?
No matter if you're ranking or not, so.
100%.
And at the end of the day also, it doesn't,
I mean, it does matter how many leads you get them,
but what I always try to,
I always try when I get questions like that,
I try to let them know,
hey, this isn't about how many leads I get you.
This is about how much money you make, right?
Because if I only sent you three leads a month,
but you knew you were gonna close all three of those deals
and you were gonna make X amount of money,
you know, that was gonna be a three X
on the money you're spending with me,
you wouldn't care how many leads.
So at the end of the day, I always like to let them know
and like try to frame it as like,
I care more about how much money they make
than I do about how many leads I'm getting them,
because I know I could get them 100 leads a month,
but if they're not making money,
whether it's my fault or not,
they're going to eventually cancel.
So that's number one.
The other thing you have to just set expectations
that I would just add,
and I think that we do this more during the actual sale
when you're closing the deal,
is I like to let them know,
the reason that we do a six month contract
is because we're gonna take the average of the six months.
Okay, we're gonna take the average
of how many leads came in,
how many deals were closed,
how much money was made,
how much money was put in their pocket
over a six month period.
Because if we look at one month,
let's say we do a deal,
and I always explain this to the business owner,
I say, hey, Mr. Business Owner, it's spring,
we just got tax returns back,
everyone's spending money on cleaning up the yard.
If we do a one month deal in April,
because it's tax season,
and we get you X amount of leads,
is it safe to assume that we're gonna get you
that many leads every single month?
And of course the answer is no,
because that's gonna be a really good month, right?
And likewise, if it's December,
and I only get you one lead,
because it's Christmas and no one wants to spend,
is it safe to assume that every month
is gonna be like that?
Well, no, of course not.
So, okay, Mr. Business Owner, just so you know,
the reason we're doing this for six months
is I need you to be patient with me.
We're gonna have some months that are gonna be great,
we're gonna have some months
that are not gonna be great,
we're gonna have some days
you're gonna get multiple leads,
we're gonna have some weeks that you get no leads.
But the thing that we're looking at
is the average of the six months.
And so that's why I need you to give me
this six month period.
At the end of the six months,
if you've done your job and I've done my job
and it's just not working,
then trust me, I'll be the first one to cut this thing off.
That's it.
It's the pullback, but it's also just being real.
Like, it's so, sometimes it's so hard to like,
you know, we were getting the deal and we're excited,
and we want every,
we wanna give everyone the best answer, right?
So, you know, people are like,
hey, so, you know, how quickly will you have this done?
And sometimes we're like, we wanna be like,
yeah, it'll be done in two days
because it's been that way before,
but we don't know for sure.
And we somehow wanna impress this client
and we say stupid stuff that keeps like, ties us in.
It's so much better to just pause and go,
you know what, we've done it in as little as a few days,
but just to be realistic with you,
I would plan on like giving us at minimum,
you know, seven to 10 days,
just in case something happens.
I'd rather just, you know, plan on that
and then surprise you.
You have no idea.
Do you know what?
Every single time you do something like that,
it builds trust.
Every time you do that,
you're different than the last person.
You're different than the last person that told you,
hey, we're gonna get X amount of leads
and we're gonna blow it up and blah, blah, blah,
and then nothing ever happened, right?
So, I love what Matthew said
and it's, I would kind of call that a pullback,
but the deal's already done,
but I would just say just being real
and just being like transparent
and giving an honest answer,
instead of like giving the best case,
give the worst case, okay?
And when you do that,
what we think sometimes it's gonna lose us the deal,
it's gonna make it so we're not gonna get the deal.
Actually, it's gonna solidify the deal.
Actually, it's going to make it seem
like we're actually legitimate and we're real
and we're gonna take care of them.